[Music]
starwars by the numbers in the first six
films there have only been eleven
lightsaber battles which resulted in
nine severed hands stormtroopers scored
only 58 visible kills in the first three
movies and in the first film a hit a
main character only once and it was a
stun blast Darth Vader on the other hand
had a body count of ten even still in
1977 twenty nine babies in the US were
named Darth in 2014 two hundred eighteen
babies were named Anakin 605 named Leia
and ten thousand four hundred thirty-one
named Luke of course that one's also in
the Bible in 2011 one hundred seventy
six thousand six hundred thirty two
census responders in the UK reported
Jedi as their religion but it's also big
money more than two hundred million star
wars lego sets were sold from 1999 to
2012 hasbro sold 5.5 billion dollars
worth of action figures Harrison Ford
was paid $10,000 for Star Wars a new
hope he is now worth 210 million dollars
George Lucas was paid $175,000 for a new
Hulk he is now worth 5.2 billion
and Star Wars collectible coins are even
accepted as currency in new way a tiny
island nation in the Pacific in 2007
NASA sent one lightsaber from the movie
into space bringing it slightly closer
to a galaxy far far away that featured
17 different planets two moons and 132
different species of life in the first
six films as well as complex languages
such as II walk language which was
comprised of at least two human
languages and Wookiee which included the
sounds of bears walruses lions and
Badgers and while Star Wars a new hope
may have started small being released in
a total of 43 theaters the force awakens
is predicted to open in more than 5500
theaters and over 10,000 screens
the Star Wars universe has raked in over
37 billion dollars and the force awakens
is projected to gross anywhere from 1.2
billion to three billion dollars and
ticket sales alone
it looks like the force is strong with
this one
[Music]
you